we have all experienced some kind of
nerve injury in our lifespan this could
be in our central nervous system or in
the peripheral nervous system imagine
you have cut your hand with a knife
Central and peripheral nervous system
has different degree of repairing
capability pns repairs quickly
unfortunately CNS cannot repair itself
very efficiently there are different
nerve injuries like neuropraxia which is
a compression of the overall endoneurium
and the myelin sheath of the nerve
is bit more intense the axon is
disrupted as well as the myelin is lost
but the endoneurium is intact
neurotomesis involves axon loss myelin
loss as well as the loss of endoneurium
in case of nerve injury the axon which
is injured would eventually degrade and
die and this is known as Valerian
degeneration watch the full video to
know more